Bolted.
The Siberian Husky is remembered for
leading a team of sled dogs to deliver
medicine that saved the town of Nome,
Alaska from a deadly epidemic.
He became a national hero and this
photo was on the front page of every
newspaper in the country.
The statue was erected in his honor in
central park in 1925 and it is still one
of the most beloved tourist
attractions to this very day.
Many of you might have seen the animated
film by universal pictures and that
might be all you know about Baltic,
but the true story is far more dramatic
than what you ever learned from cartoons
and children's books.
And in the video today,
we're bringing you the story of Bulto,
the canine hero.
A story begins in the remote town of Nome,
Alaska in the 1890s the name gold rush
brought prospectors to this small town in
the hopes of making a rich.
There were no paved roads,
so it was incredibly difficult
for people to get around,
especially in the winter.
Many of the people who move to know Matt
to adjust to life in Alaska and they
became a very tight knit community.
These people,
they had a lot of respect for one
another because they were all managing to
survive in the American wilderness
if anyone was struggling.
Neighbors helped one another out without
hesitation and it really fostered a
close knit community and our
region man named Leon Hart's.
Seppala owns a dog Kennel in Nome,
so pilar is creditors that being the first
man to introduce Russia's working dog
breed from Siberia to the United States
and they later got the name Siberian
Husky. These dogs became so popular in
Alaska that he decided to breed them for a
living. He was only interested in breeding
dogs that were light and we're fast.
He became one of the first
men to participate in
competitive dog sled racing in
the United States.
One of the many puppies that was born
in Isabella's Kennel was named Bolty.
He was born with Brown eyes and black
with white socks on his two front legs,
but also it was apparently too large
and it was considered a scrub doc.
Supposed to had him neutered right away
because he was deemed to be at far too
inferior to pass on his DNA.
Balto was born between the years 1919
in 1923 but no one can be quite sure of
the exact date.
Isabella.
Essentially it was breeding so many
dogs that he didn't really keep track of
every puppy that he declared or reject
for all of the other dogs that did not
suit his needs.
Apollo would rent them out to members of
the community to use for building their
dog sleds in the Windsor Dog sleds became
the only option for traveling out of
town, so trade gold for supplies.
Since so many men traveled to know,
looking for jobs in the mining industry,
so parlor was able to make a fortune
horrendous thing out as well as selling as
docs parlors.
Favorite Tasky was called Togo.
He was considered to be a perfect husky
specimen who was incredibly light and
muscular.
As the story goes,
Togo was so fast that he could race a
train and when so supposedly he had all of
his time and energy and do training.
This favorite dog offers a
man named Gunnar Carson had
moved from Norway to Nome,
Alaska to take part in the gold rush.
He paid the rents upon as
dogs do transport supplies
to many were working in the
gold mines. There is no record of why
cousin chose bolt to be his lead dog,
but most people believe it was because
he felt some kind of connection from the
start. Most mushers juice a dog to
lead that they know they can trust.
He saw something special in Baltimore
and the decision to take him home,
it was one day you're
going to save his life.
No one was having one of the
coldest winters on record.
Temperatures were reaching
minus 50 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is minus 45 degrees Celsius.
Wins were 50 miles or around 80 kilometers
per hour that were several terrible
blizzards that may travel conditions
impossible and most people had no choice
but to isolate themselves in their
homes and just stay by the fire place.
In December of 1924 a record number of
children were going to the only doctor in
town, Curtis Welch. At first,
Dr. Welch thought that these
children simply had a sore
throat and their parents,
they tried to nurse them back to health
over the holidays. A few weeks later,
in January of 1925 two children
unfortunately died. It was at this point,
the Dr. Welch realized that
this was actually a highly
contagious disease called
diptheria and did an infected
most of the children in town.
The native Inuit children were affected
the worst because diptheria was a white
man's to seize this illness was nicknamed
the strangling angel because the
inside of the throat begins to turn to
leather and people can no longer breathe
or swallow. Children were far
more susceptible to catching
diptheria than adults,
so parents were watching helplessly as
their sons and daughters were slowly
choking to death. Dr. Welch announced that
all of the children who were infected,
it needed to be placed in quarantine
in order to prevent an epidemic.
The cure for diptheria it existed,
but no one was not equipped to
treat such a massive outbreak.
They needed a medicine
called antitoxins serum.
Since Dr. Welch and his four nurses with
the only medical professionals in town,
they were working around the
clock to treat those children.
The total population of
Knome was just 10,000 people,
and even after placing the infected under
quarantine, it was already too late.
More people that were getting
sick every single day.
Everyone was afraid that if
the outbreak was not contained,
all of the children may die and it
may spread to the adults as well.
On January the 22nd 1925 Dr. Welch
sent out dozens of telegrams to doctors
around Alaska and even sent a message
to Washington DC hoping for the help to
get enough antitoxin. They were eager
to help, but the issue was delivery.
The winds were far too strong for
a plane to travel through that,
whether it's that was too much ice for
a ship to reach the harbor city where
medicine could be
delivered with anchorage,
but the train stopped
in a town called Nanana,
which was 674 miles away from Nome.
The only choice was to take sled
dogs across the snowy Iditarod trail,
which was normally a 15 to 20 day journey.
There were plenty of obstacles in the
way that slowed down such a journey,
mountains, steep crevasses, and as
the frozen Yukon River, I'll ask us,
territorial governor Scott and Boone
approved the plan for the best mushers to
participate in a relay to a
guide that teams of sled dogs.
The plan was for 20 men and 150 dogs
to wait at checkpoints where they would
pass off the antitoxin to the next team,
so they were able to transport the
medicine as quickly and as efficiently as
possible.
The first men to pick up the antitoxin
at the train station in Nunno was named
at Wild Bill Shannon.
He traveled for 24 hours straight and
minus 60 degree weather to get to the
first checkpoint and other of the mushers.
Bill Mccarthy,
you came prepared with this,
our moccasins for his dog's feet so that
they wouldn't have to walk on the ice
with that bear paws.
Land on Zapala volunteered stick,
the most dangerous part of the journey
since he had the most experience,
but he was very concerned with going fast
and ordering his dog to go as fast as
he could, just like you would in a race.
He saw a man called Henry Ivan off,
stopped on the trail because he was
struggling with disobedient dogs.
A parlor chose to ignore him and
sped past, instead of offering help,
Ivan offensive runoff to Sapelo housing,
the serum, the serum, I have it here.
Thankfully it's Apollo hurt him and it
was able to turn this state around and
pick up the medicine,
but his need for speed,
it very nearly blew the entire mission.
Since Dr. Welch should send telegrams
all over the country a few days earlier,
stories of the epidemic we're
being printed in newspapers
in the lower 48 states.
This story,
it was gripping and it was tragic and
it could have been right out of a novel.
Unbeknownst to the 20 minute people all
over the United States began to hope and
pray that they would make it
just days before this happens.
Hardly anyone had even heard of Nome,
Alaska Butts.
Once they knew so many young lives were
at stake, everyone was rooting for them.
Gunna Carson had taken the Iditarod trail
together with Balto several times on
their supply runs,
so we volunteered to be one of the 20
men that helped retrieve the medicine.
Unlike land how'd Cipolla
and the other men,
Carson did not compete in dog racing,
but also was his pat when
they weren't working together.
Carson was very quiet and
shy around other people,
so [inaudible] was his best friends
and he knew he could rely on him.
Karsten was considered to be a novice
compared to the rest of the crew.
Therefore, he was given one of
the easiest legs of the trail,
but also in constant really did lead a
team of underdogs in more ways than one,
but no one could predict what
was gonna happen next. Well,
going to cost and was on his leg of
the journey, a terrible storm again.
Each one of the checkpoints stations
received a message that the serum and run
was temporarily canceled
because it was too dangerous,
but constant was already in the
wilderness with all of the antitoxin.
When the visit hit, he obviously had
no way of getting the memo. Also,
there was nowhere for him to take
shelter until the storm blew over.
The blizzard caused a White House.
Carson could not even see his hand
in front of his face. That's alone,
have a sense of direction.
He stopped moving for two hours cuddling
next to bolt the rest of his sled dogs.
He was hoping that the storm would
pass and they could carry on. However,
he could not stop thinking
about the children in the
hospital with every passing
minute and other child could die without
the medicine and if he waited much
longer, it was likely that they
would not survive the night.
He decided that his only option was to
move forward despite not being able to
see anything gonna cost and had to
put all of his faith and his dog.
Baltic dogs have a far better sense
of direction than humans. Balsa,
who had been through the trail many
times before the dog was leading the way,
using a census to guide the rest of
the team to why they needed to go.
At one point they were
hit by a wind tunnel.
It was so strong that it
knocked over the sled.
The medicine went flying
into a large snowbank.
Carson could not find
it for a very long time.
He got down on his hands and knees and
he started digging through the snow
before he finally found the antitoxin.
Also in the team,
they finally reached a
town called port safety,
which was the next checkpoint
and the relay. However,
he arrived in the middle of the night
and since the next musher had been told
the relay was canceled,
he and the dogs had fallen asleep
with just 12 miles left to go.
Carson decided to push through the
last leg of the journey himself.
When they arrived back in Nome,
it was five 30 in the morning and he went
straight to Dr. Welch once the vaccine
thought he was able to administer it to
the infected children and they will made
a full recovery.
Soon after arriving back in Nome,
journalists from all over
the United States began to
contact going to Carson and
asked for an interview so that they
could hear the story of his near death
experience, bringing the
antitoxin to the sick children.
He was always humble and downplayed his
involvement in securing the medicine.
He says to the other drivers and dogs,
the most creditors do.
They're the heart and mush
more difficulties for them.
I know I can say yes for myself.
We were glad to serve
Americans all over the country.
They wanted to meet ball too,
and children love listening to the
story of this real life. Dog Hero.
Balto was invited to the
Biltmore hotel in Los Angeles.
Gunner Carsten agreed to the interview
and he was shocked to see movie stars
showing up to have their
picture taken with the dog.
Normally a national hero is welcome
to Los Angeles with keys to the city,
but Balsa was given the boons to the
city and stat paramount pictures,
hard hardball too,
and going to Carson to star
in a dramatized documentary
gold bolters rest at
noon. It became a blockbuster hit in
1925 they made copies of the film,
but there was a studio fire in the
1930s the destroyed them all. So sadly,
this movie no longer exists.
They traveled by train across the whole
country and in December of 1925 they
arrived in New York City.
Balto was put on stage on Broadway
for a week and a Vaudeville show.
He also posed for a sculptor who created
the bras statue that stands in central
park. There was a ceremony
that unveiled the bolt statue,
which included a plaque that said
dedicated to the indomitable spirit of the
sled dogs that are relayed antitoxins
600 miles over rough ice across
treacherous waters through Arctic
blizzards from Nanana to the relief of the
stricken gnome in the winter of 1925
endurance fidelity intelligence.
Even though the statue was meant
to commemorate all of the 150 dogs,
it was clear that Balto was
the only one in the limelight.
Then announced Apollo was
still Balto is true owner,
but going to Carson was getting
all of the credit. So Paula,
he was jealous of this because he had
dedicated the majority of his life to
breeding and racing dogs.
He also took the most risk during the
journey by volunteering for the most
dangerous portion of the trail.
By this logic,
he thought that he would have gotten
all of the glory and it was truly a low
blow for the least skilled musher
and dogs to get all of the attention.
Not only that,
but he also was angry that bolter who
he considered a subpar dog was now
representing the sub area and Husky breed.
He believed that he and Togo
deserve to be on the front page,
not those damages any he to Nome,
Alaska after a year long American tour
going to cost and found that support a
lot.
It wasn't the only one who was upset.
The community was split between those
who believe to Togo deserved the
recognition and those who supported Balti.
Some even accused costs of skipping the
last stop on purpose because he would
have known this.
The sled to arrive in town with a
medicine would have gotten all the glory,
but many historians do not believe that
Carson could possibly be motivated by
famed.
He would've had no way of knowing that
the whole country was waiting to hear
news about the small town
in the middle of Alaska.
He was simply too busy and just trying
to stay alive for suppose polar.
The statue of Baltar in central park,
it was the last straw.
He wanted to get rid of ball too and
decided that he needed to go on his own
door with Togo in an attempt to
brand him as the true dog heroin.
He and his manager,
they planned a huge spectacle of traveling
to New York City to write his team of
dogs down Broadway and end up at Madison
Square Garden, but even on these tours,
children, they were still asking about
Balsa. No matter how hard he tries people,
it's still loved the adorable
black Husky with white socks,
that that is musher through a visit.
Since they announced Apollo
was still a Bartos legal owner,
he decided to get rid of him for good by
putting bulto into the rest of the dog
team up for auction.
Go to Carson was mortified and he could
not afford to bid on Balto to save him
from his fate. When Baltar was
sold, Carson lost his best friends.
He was never the same again.
Balto when the rest of the dog so deem
they were sold to a man named Sam Houston
who put them on display.
It is dime museum in Los Angeles.
These were typically filled
with oddities and freed shows.
People paid a dime for a ticket to go
around and stare at the live attractions.
The dogs would change the
wall all day every day.
They were not allowed to run or to play,
and Houston hardly fed them and
they became sick with mange.
In 1927 a man named George
Kimball from Cleveland,
Ohio was visiting Los Angeles and he
bought a ticket to the Sam Houston dime
museum.
This is where he found bolted.
Kimble read all the
stories in the newspapers,
so it was horrified to see these
heroic dogs being mistreated.
They asked Sam Houston what it
would take to buy balls, him,
and he was told that it would take
$2,000 off to modern day inflation.
That's more like $28,000 George
Campbell could not afford that himself.
So when he returned to Cleveland's,
he began a campaign to save Baltic.
The story of the dog's heroic ms
treatments. It ran in the local newspaper.
Citizens of Cleveland donated
whatever they could afford.
Even young children brought their pennies
to Campbell's campaign hoping to save
their heroin.
10 days later,
they had raised enough money to buy Balto
and they had a little extra leftover
to save his friends as well.
When the dog's arrived in Cleveland's,
they were finally allowed to pull a sled
again as a team and a crowd of 15,000
people lining the street,
sharing and giving the dogs a
standing ovation and the city.
It didn't stop that
citizens of Cleveland's.
They put together the money to build.
The dog is a large enclosure at the zoo
with a grassy field for them to run and
play.
The city considered them to be their paps.
They were given more love and
attention than most docs have.
A get ballsy remained at the
Cleveland Zoo for the next six years.
When he was between 11 and 14 years old,
he became very sick and
he could barely walk.
When children heard that he was
missing from the grass enclosure,
they would call the zoo every day
asking for updates to see if bolt I was
feeling better.
But the veterinarians,
they knew that it was more humane
to put them to sleep. When Balsa,
who died the entire
country Mont it's death,
it was once again on the
front page of every paper.
People loved him so much they
didn't want to let him go. So bold,
whose body it was turned into a taxidermy
figure is remains when we've to the
Cleveland Museum of natural history.
Ever since then,
children go on school trips to see Balto
and hear the story of the race to save
Noman for all his efforts to
raise [inaudible] from history.
So Paula failed to insert himself in Togo
into the limelight to the extents that
Balto had been that so go farther dozens
of puppies. And when he grew older,
he had a very comfortable doggy retirement
living with a family friend in Poland,
spring, Maine. When he died,
his body was also stuffed and mounted
at the Peabody museum of natural history
at Yale University.
However,
it was never preserved properly and
children were touching and petting Togo so
much that the taxi, damn,
you'd figure that came damaged.
He eventually had to be removed from the
museum even after the dogs had passed
away.
There was still plenty of people in
this lending community who believed that
Togo truly deserved the
fame over [inaudible].
But what we do know for sure is that if
it were not for Gunnar Carson's complete
trust and is brave dog,
the entire team would have
frozen to death in that blizzard.
The vaccine for Knome would have been
buried under piles of snow and there is no
telling how many people
would have died as a result.
But what we do know is that
ball to the dog was a hero.
I'm certainly a very
good boy back in Alaska,
going to cost and live to quiet life.
Years later, his niece, Janice Wayland's,
asked her uncle to tell her the story
of what really happens with bolty since
she had had so many different versions
of the story from children at school.
He replied, I will tell you this once
and only once if it wasn't football,
so I wouldn't be alive today.
And so I already have you found that video
interesting and inspiring. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just
like this several times a week.
So hit that subscribe button,
normalcy the bell notification,
because the subscriptions on Youtube,
they don't do what they used to.
If you want to actually get a
notification when we put out a video,
do hit that bell and as always,
thank you for watching.